My colleague Liz Dunn at University of British
Columbia and I have been studying the relationship
with between money and happiness.
And it seems like a simple relationship, which
is: we want more money and we want more happiness,
so maybe if we get more money we’ll get
more happiness.
And it turns out that the relationship is
really a lot more complicated than that.
It’s not too surprising to say that money
can’t buy you happiness, we’ve heard that
phrase a lot.
But that doesn’t help us understand then
what kind of spending will actually make us
happy and what kind won’t.
What we tend to find when we look at the data
is that the biggest category of things that
people spend on is stuff for themselves.
Of course we need to pay rent or our mortgage,
we need to have a car, we need to have food
and clothes, but it seems as though people
are spending an inordinate amount of their
money on stuff for themselves, and the biggest
problem from our standpoint as psychologists
is the percent of money that you spend on
stuff for yourself is completely uncorrelated
with how happy you are with your life.
It doesn’t make you unhappy, it’s not
like if you buy a lot of stuff you’re miserable,
which sometimes we think is the case—it’s
just the case that it’s flat.
No matter how much it seems you buy for yourself,
nothing really seems to happen.
And so in our research, and other researchers
as well, we’ve tried to look at, well, if
stuff for yourself doesn’t pay off are there
other things that you can spend your money
on that actually do pay off in more happiness?
And what Liz and I have focused on the most
is this idea that instead of focusing on yourself
all the time, which doesn’t seem to pay
off in happiness, when you focus on other
people you sort of reverse the arrow from
me to you, it seems that on average when people
give to others—which can be giving to charity,
it can be treating a friend to lunch, it can
be buying people gifts—that those actions
of giving rather than keeping seem to be associated
with more happiness.
And when we send people out and give them
money and tell them to spend it on themselves
or spend it on somebody else, people who spend
it on themselves kind of have the same day
they would’ve had anyway, but people who
spend on other people actually have a happier
day.
So, if you think about the idea that stuff
for yourself doesn’t make you happy you
can think of two opposites of that.
One is stuff for other people, so that’s
kind of giving makes you happier than keeping,
but another opposite of stuff for yourself
is to think about: you can still spend on
yourself but change from stuff to something
else.
And lots of research over the last decade
has shown that on average when people buy
experiences it tends to pay off in more happiness
than buying stuff for themselves.
And if you think about it there’s a lot
of reasons for that.
One of them, which is really critical, is
often when we buy stuff for ourselves we end
up by ourselves with our stuff.
Think of yourself on your phone playing a
video game or whatever else it might be, you’re
often alone with your stuff.
Whereas experiences, yes we do some experiences
solo, but many, many experiences have built
into them that they’re social.
If we go out to dinner or go see a movie or
go on a hike or whatever else it might be,
now we’re with other people and even though
people sometimes annoy us a lot it turns out
that talking to other people makes us happy,
even casual interactions with other people
make us happier than sitting by ourselves
in a room.
So experiences are more interesting and all
those things, but they also actually kind
of serve to commit us to spending time with
other people, and that’s partly why experiences
pay off in so much more happiness.